(soft music)
- [Narrator] We are the
paradoxical ape, bipedal, naked,
large brained, long the master
of fire, tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves,
aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here,
an exploration made possible by
the generosity of humans like you.
(upbeat music)
- So, I'm going to extend some
of the points that Rusty raised,
but in particular, in the
context of this structure,
which is the cerebral cortex.
So, I think most would be familiar,
this large folded structure here
at the top is the cerebral cortex.
It makes up about three quarters
of the volume of the human
central nervous system
and I think most people in this room
know functionally how important it is.
It is, as I say, this sort of executive
and integrative center of
the central nervous system.
And it's a huge amount of real estate,
it does important things, so it's
affected by a variety of diseases
that have their etiology, or their impact,
at different stages in age, starting from
conditions with a very
early onset in childhood,
like autism, and right through
to diseases of later life
like dementia or stroke
and those kind of things.
So, what I'm gonna talk about today
is how do we start dealing with questions
about how do you control the development
of the cerebral cortex,
particularly in terms of size,
as of sort of a simple concept.
And as I'm sure you've heard
in previous Carta symposiums,
and you'll hear this afternoon,
there's a lot of debate about
sort of cognitive capacity
or cognitive ability and
its anatomical underpinnings
and there is bigger brains
make you smarter and so on,
but there's some degree of
grievance around the idea
that certainly more neurons
give you more processing power
at its most basic rate.
Complexity is probably
very important as well,
in terms of elements that
one can build circuits from
and what you do with
them, so raw real estate
is also quite important.
And that becomes very obvious
when you start looking
at these sort of three
cherry picked primates here.
We've also got humans,
chimp, and rhesus macaque
and what we're looking at
here is the number of neurons
in each cerebral cortex, where you can see
that humans have roughly
three fold as many
compared to chimpanzee,
even though, in terms
of actual developmental time, so you know,
I could ask how long do
humans take to develop,
easy one for us to all
answer, nine months.
The chimp is roughly the
same, but you still end up
with a brain which has a cortex
with about a third of
the number of neurons.
Then, macaque, which is shortened again,
but has you know, ten fold fewer neurons.
So, there's a very basic
development ability question,
is how do different organisms generate
different numbers of neurons
within their cerebral cortex?
And at what level is it controlled?
And by understanding
that question of control,
can we start thinking
about how you might then
evolve these differences
between different species
and it plugs into the kind of genetics
and that kind of work that you'll
be hearing about later in the afternoon.
So, to think about this, you've
got to think about developmental biology,
which is how do you actually make things
in the cortex in the first place.
And this is a picture from a mouse brain,
where this red thing, this is a
slice through the mouse brain,
this will be the outside,
this will be the inside.
What all these little red blobs are
is these are what we would
call progenitor cell.
For the sake of simplicity, I'll
call them cortical stem cells.
So, these guys aren't neurons.
This is before you have
any neurons in your brain,
or in this case, the mouse brain.
This is a slice this way through
one half of your cerebral cortex.
So, the skin would be
out here, for example.
There's a hole in the
center of the brain here.
And these guys are lined up in a row,
and what happens is
these cortical stem cells
go on, and this is done in black,
to generate cortical neurons that are
arranged in layers over time.
So, you do this inside or develop them
to make the deep layers where
you make the upper levels
and so on, and this is a
very stereotyped program
that plays out in every
single mouse in the same way.
And in a mouse, it takes about six days
to generate all of these cells.
So, that's fine, so you've got
one bib population of stem cells.
There's a very interesting
biology about them,
how they diversify, but at heart,
these guys make all of
this cast of neurons.
So, when you're thinking
about how you build a brain,
you've gotta think about how they do this,
but a key concept within
this is what is the output
of each one of those cortical stem cells?
And there's a principal
in development here
where we talk about a clone.
Now, this isn't Dolly
the sheep type clone,
this is a different clone, just to
make your life slightly more complicated.
At the very basic idea, what
is in a mind experiment,
if you could label one of those red cells
on the previous slide
with an indelible marker,
so every time it divides,
it's daughter cells
inherit the indelible marker and then
develop and play out over time.
What you'd end up doing is
labeling every single cell
it made, just passively
by letting it roll.
So, that's the idea.
So, you label it all.
So, if we're doing this
in the cortex, we take,
we know what the start of
cortical development looks like,
we've got these progenitor cells lined up.
We call this an epithelium, basically,
and we know what it looks
like at the end of development
where you've got these layers of neurons
and we've got little labels
that let us tell them apart.
The mind experiment,
and the real experiment,
is you then label one of these
guys with an indelible marker
and let time play out.
And you do this and you look at
thousands and thousands of these.
What do you find as something very simple?
If you do this before
you make any neurons,
you end up with purple spots
that cross all the layers
and make all of the cells.
And what that tells you is you've got this
fundamental principle where
each cortical stem cell
will make a clone of cells that populates
all of the different neuronal types.
And so what that tells you then,
is that your clone is this sort
of atomic unit of building,
a structure within the nervous system.
So, let's do the cortex
example I've given here,
it's actually true in your spinal cord,
your eye, and so on, and what that does
is it gives you an idea of
thinking about this problem
of at a kind of comparative
development label,
how do you make a bigger cortex in, say,
a human compared to a macaque or a chimp?
And it's actually very simple.
So, if you think about it in clonal terms,
either have more clones,
so increase the number
of stem cells before you
ever even make the structure,
or actually change what
each stem cell does
in terms of what the
output of its clone is.
So, make the sort of production
from that clone larger
and it's a way of ending
up with more neurons.
An example I've done
on here, this is mouse,
and my mice are, for
want of a better term,
relatively simple in this respect,
which is, they have phases.
This is your starting stem cell,
it proliferates and then
it has this linear program.
It expands itself, then
it starts making neurons,
during which, it depletes itself,
'cause you're eating up
stem cells to make neurons,
and then they switch to
make these supporting, or
these second cell type in the
nervous system, the astrocyte,
which is actually
functionally very important.
And it's a nice, linear program.
So, one of the big
questions in the field is
when you start getting to primates,
how complicated does this get?
Do you just take the simple template
and just make more of them?
And you just generate
more real estate that way,
or do you diversify just to
make it much more complicated?
And how would this work?
And if you can understand that,
then you can start plugging in
the kind of molecular genetic stuff,
like, well how does this
work within all this?
And the question of how do you study this,
and labeling single cortical stem cells
in the human might get you in trouble
in most jurisdictions at this point.
So, we did something similar
to what Rusty spoke of,
where in this case, we were very much
focused on the cerebral cortex.
So, we started with human, and we took
human embryonic stem cells, or these
induced progenitor stem
cells that Rusty mentioned,
and what we essentially
worked out how to do,
using principles of developmental biology
is make the cortical, just
the cortical neural stem cell
and they formed into pretty
rosettes within this.
And what we found is, we
could put them into the dish
and they would replay this
generating the layers of neurons
on exactly a timescale that
they do in normal development,
but in utero, which was
a bit of a surprise.
And they actually go on and they make
these beautifully connected networks.
So, these are neurons which
are firing away happily,
these human neurons.
So, this was a bit of a surprise to us
that they observed rules even
though they were isolated
from the sort of whole embryo.
So, we then extended this and said,
what happens if we look at
these different species?
And so, this was worked on by
Tomoki Otani when he was in
the lab, and this is actually
collaboration with Carol
Barchetta, who you heard
mentioned by Rusty, and
actually, Eliza Courno,
at the Primate Research
Institute up in Seattle.
What essentially we did was
work out how to make pure cortex
from these cerebral cortexes
from these different species
in the lab and this is
John Gerden, by the way,
down at the bottom, for
those of you who don't know,
but we don't actually have John's IPSL's.
We think there's a market for them,
but a rather dodgy market
for them, but anyway.
So, this is chimp, and these are actually
two different species of macaque,
because we could get access to them.
So, we could make the cortical stem cells
and they could replay development
and what we found was each species,
just as it does in sort in utero,
has a developmental time scale,
which it observes in the
lab, by which I mean,
the green cells here, so the bottom line
of each one of these graphs here is time
and the green are those
deep layers of neurons
and the red is these later born neurons,
so every species makes green before red,
but what happens is the macaque makes red
much sooner than the
human does and the chimp.
And actually, the human and the chimp
look remarkably similar at the resolution
that we can look at with
these kind of assets.
So, in fact, the rest
of what I'll talk about,
we just look at human and macaque,
because actually human and
chimp look very similar,
which is actually kind of reassuring,
'cause you'd want them to
look very similar, given
what you've heard about in
terms of genome similarities.
So, every species has a schedule
and I should say the schedule
is remarkably similar
to what happens in utero.
And we extended this to all sorts
of other analysis, which I
won't go into detail with here,
including when do they make neurons,
when do they make different
classes of neurons,
and the kind of electrophysiology
you heard about,
when do they mature, when
do they form networks.
So, what this provides us now,
is a platform to start asking
the mechanistic questions I mentioned,
which is, well how does the stem cell
that actually generates the neurons
within each species behave
in terms of making a cortex?
And what that involved
doing is, in the lab version
of the experiment I just described,
where we label just one stem cell
in a population of tens of thousands
and actually watch that over time
and then look at lots of
individual stem cells.
And to do that, we use a
trick where we take a virus,
which is essentially,
we've sort of damaged,
so this virus can infect a cell,
but then it can never get back out again,
so it brings the marker,
the marker then stays,
so these are what we call
replication of common viruses.
This is a rosette made up of,
each one of these blobs is a stem cell.
We labeled one stem cell.
And then we follow this
thing dividing over say,
10 days within the lab, and
we can reconstruct the clone.
And one of the challenges
here is, as we mentioned,
primate development is
very long and very slow.
So, to give you some kind of benchmark,
mice will take over the
world, and the reason
mice will take over the world is they do
all of their development
in less than 21 days
and they'll generate litters of, well,
you know, those of you who've
been unfortunate enough
to have your garage overrun by mice,
as opposed to humans, and we
know how long humans take.
So, what happens is,
these, and I mentioned that
mice will make the cortical
neurons at six days,
humans will do it over
four, five, six months,
and so you get an idea that
these clones become enormous.
So, we have to look at
them in blocks of 10 days,
so sort of the first 10 days,
the second 10 days, and so on
and the first thing we can do
is start measuring, you know,
what do they make and how do they make it?
And as biologists, we tend
to think biology's a mess.
There are kind of rules,
but they're a bit dodgy,
and it's a bit tricky to make sense of it.
It's all about extracting order form chaos
and physicists think
we're a bunch of Luddites
and that we just can't think straight
and there are clearly
physicists in the audience,
I heard some snickering.
And a colleague and friend
of mine and can be true
as a physicist called
Ben Simon says actually,
"You biologists, actually if
you take the complex data,
you do some very important
principles underlying them."
And said, "Right, prove it."
And so, he did.
So, he took all this kind of data
and he ripped them apart and rather than
me boring you for 10 minutes
with all the details,
I'll give you the punchline,
which is what I told him to tell me, too,
which is that essentially,
when we start looking at,
for example, this is how many stem cells
are within a clone over time, and this is,
in the first 10 days, for
example, 20 days, gray,
the next 10 days, black
is the next 10 days.
And you see actually in
each window of 10 days,
humans all look the same, and
what's happening over time is
within the clone, they're
actually expanding the number
of stem cells in the clone
while making neurons,
so they're kind of, the whole
thing's growing exponentially.
Macaque's start off
looking very like human
and then they crash, and what
that really means is that
essentially, the macaques
stop making neurons
much sooner than the humans do.
And it's a very simple thing.
What it means is that the humans
make these big, long extended clones,
which allow them to make far more neurons
over a much longer period of time,
so they'll make more neurons per stem cell
and they do it kinda clever ways,
stuff that I wouldn't get into today.
Now, that's all fine and
it's very descriptive,
and it raises the second question,
which is well fine, how does this work?
Now, there's a very broad
distinction we like to make,
which is, how much of this biology
is controlled intrinsically?
Whatever that means in terms of mechanism.
And how much is controlled externally?
Signaling environment,
you could boil it down to,
you know, this sort of nature nurture,
who do you know, what do you know,
but you get the basic principle.
I once heard that one referred to
the European versus the American model,
but I couldn't work out which one
was meant to be certainly
not complementary,
but anyway, so in this
case, what we can do,
is we can essentially do transplantation.
Now, clearly, I'm not gonna get a license
to transplant macaque cells into humans.
And probably not the
other way around either,
but what we can do, is we can
do transplantation in the lab,
where we can label up,
say, the human stem cell
and the macaque stem cell and then move,
say one and 1,000 of those
into the other environment.
So, essentially, you're exposing them
to the other species' environment
and asking, now what will
they do at its simplest.
And we can then roll them out
over time and do all our maths
and essentially, all I'm showing you here
is that nothing changes, so
I give you the punchline,
which is the number of
neurons a stem cell makes
is actually intrinsic to the species.
It's got nothing to do
with the environment.
At the resolution of this assay,
with all sorts of caveats around it
with what we're measuring,
by which we mean,
if I move macaque into
human, macaque doesn't care.
It'll still make what it wants to make,
when it should make it.
And similarly, with the human,
if I move human into
macaque, it'll still generate
a certain number of cells.
So, that's quite striking,
but it's about numbers.
There's a second readout,
which is very important,
which I've rather glossed over,
which is this, what neurons do you make
and when do you make them?
So, this idea's switching
from the early born neurons
to the later born neurons I mentioned.
And this was a think I
mentioned, so we make layers,
we mentioned this, but
also, the humans here
switch to making these red guys
much later than the
macaque do, for example,
and we can look at this, as
well, within these systems,
and again, what we find is that,
if you look at these pie charts,
this pie chart looks similar,
identical to this pie chart.
What we're doing here is
putting human into human,
or human in macaque or vice
versa, macaque into human,
or macaque into macaque and essentially,
the species don't care.
They're going to do what
they're going to do.
They're sort of like my
11 year old son, you know.
In the sense that, it doesn't
matter what environment,
there's a certain amount of pigheadedness.
So, what this means is,
and I don't know where
they get it from, I blame his mother.
Anyway, so what we've learned
from these kind of studies
is that the primates do
development certainly differently
and I should say something,
which I haven't the time
to go into today, they
also do it differently
to small mammals like mice.
So, this idea that you're
early on, you're expanding
your stem cells while
making your own stuff,
that's quite different
compared to small mammals.
So, there's sort of a big mammal problem
in addition to the primate problem.
And this is something which, as a field,
we haven't really grappled with yet.
You know, there are such huge differences
between the kind of
tools we use in the lab
and the model organisms we
study in the lab, like mice,
in term of their biology.
And primates, some of them
aren't to do with being primates,
they're to do with being large,
slowly developing mammals
more than anything else.
But even within this difference,
what we find is that
humans then are different
to the smaller brained primates.
And that essentially, these differences
I mentioned are cell autonomist.
And so what that then leaves us that
and this is where we are now,
is this provides us a platform to ask
what are these mechanisms?
How do we control what a stem
cell does and how it does it?
And our goal is we can identify
what those differences
are, what those sort of
cell intrinsic controls
are, and clearly, yes,
we all think about genetics and there is
an element to that, but you know,
we have to be quite broad minded about
what the kind of cell
intrinsic clocks are.
The looking at those
differences will give us insight
into evolutionary differences,
by sort of thinking backwards.
I should say there's
another side to this, too,
which is, the mechanism that controls
differences between species of brain size
are also very important
in two clinical contexts.
One is control of brain
size developmentally,
which has a very strong impact
on various intellectual disabilities
and the other side is obviously
different types of brain cancers,
because it's the same
biology there as well.
So, I'll just finish there
and just to say, I mentioned this,
this was led by Tomoki
Otani who was in the lab
not too recently and is
now with McKenzie in Tokyo
and is carried on by two
other people within the lab
that I've mentioned here, and just to say,
none of this work would've been possible
without Ben, Rusty, and
Carol, so thank you very much.
(applause)
(upbeat music)